welcome everybody to by now the
30th installment of the pi data
cambridge meetup
um we've gone fully online for about a
year a little bit more than a year now
and we're happy to share two exciting
speakers with you
tonight before we get to that few
matters of housekeeping and general
interest
so here's our agenda for tonight so
we'll have a couple of minutes
just uh introduction and then our first
speaker for the evening
is going to be george denis who's going
to talk to us about
using perceptual data to move forward to
move towards the future of virtual
reality
then we'll have a short break about five
minutes to allow for questions and a
follow-up discussion
and then our second talk of the evening
is going to be dialo
who's going to talk to us about
analyzing complex survey data
using python botox are about
half an hour in length so we expect to
be finished around
20 minutes past eight and just as a
matter of general interest we we do
record the
meetup and we make the recordings
available afterwards
so that you can catch up or share
a little bit about who we are and um
what we do
so for the regulars this is probably
already quite
familiar but we are the local meetup
chapter of
uh the pi data organization we're
normally hosted in cambridge
although these days with and that's
cambridge in the uk
um but having moved online for the
duration of the
pandemic um that boundary has blurred a
little bit
and we were inaugurated in november of
2018.
we've organized so far a monthly meetup
every last wednesday of the month
and apart from myself there's federico
leandro and ola who are the four of us
are co-organizing
the meetup so we're all volunteers and
we're sponsored by num focus to to make
the meetup happen
um and i have a little bit about num
focus
in the next slide so num focus is an
organization to
um promote open code and then for the
the purpose of
promoting better science and the my data
set of meetups is and conferences is a
part of
the num focus organization
so nonfocus does more than just
organizing meetups and conferences
they also sponsor a bunch of open source
packages
and if you've done anything with python
or r
or julia or stan chances are that you've
used one of the
non-focus sponsored packages
if you like what num focus is doing you
can contribute to their mission
either by helping out or by considering
donating
if you want
we have a code of conduct for the
meetup the code of conduct basically
boils down to
treats other people the way that you
want to be treated
so even though this is an online event
it's still a community event and we ask
you to be kind to others
and not insult or
put other people down or cause
offense or
through hurtful behavior make other
people feel unwelcome
so i think that's fairly reasonable um
nonetheless if you feel that there has
been a violation of the code of conduct
or
there's something that you're not
comfortable with how it's
transpired in the meetup you can reach
out to
to us as the organizers of the meetup
we are also partly responsible for the
enforcing the code of conduct or to
leoni mooc as a an outsider
outside of the organization of the
meetup
and then before we get started we want
to give a
shout out to our sponsors that made the
meet up possible
so they've been doing that both when we
had the in-person meet up
when they sponsored pizza and beer and
drinks and also online
and help us pay for zoom licenses and
other fees
our sponsors have some
news to share with you some job postings
if you do
end up applying for a job or you reach
out because of something that you heard
in this meetup
do mention that pi data cambridge sent
you
that's always good to spread the word
and to make sure that
to to convince them that their
sponsorship money is basically
well spent and effective
so from the side of arm there are a
couple of
career positions that they've posted out
to us
principal data engineer graduate data
engineer
data analyst and senior performance
analyst
engineer there's a link at the bottom of
the page
to the arm company careers website where
you can find more information
or you can contact federico or
leandro who are part of the organizers
of the meetup
raspberry pi is also one of our sponsors
dave gracefully hosted us when
back in the days when it was still an
in-person meetup
they have a fantastic venue full of
interesting things to to discover um
now that everybody's gone fully online
they have weekly live streams with
educational activities involving
raspberry pi
and we encourage you to check that out
at rpf dot io
slash home where you can find more
information
fetch.ai is sharing a little bit of news
about projects that they've um recently
completed or engaged with they have um
autonomous economic economic agent
manager
that's just come out in a public beta
it lets you run finished agents without
having to code
and it's supported on many different
platforms and sort of
lowers the barrier to entry if you want
to find out more
there's a link at the bottom of the page
where you can find
both more information about the
autonomous economic agent manager and
about
the architecture for the agent framework
that they've developed
they've also asked us to announce that
they are part of a automotive network
the
cantena x automotive network and you can
find a little bit more information
on linkedin which is a partnership with
different um automobile vendors
and they have also different channels
for you to reach out either via discord
or by checking out the code that they've
made available on
github in terms of jobs they have a
number of job postings
if you want to know more there's a link
in the middle of the page
fetch.ai jobs and an email address that
you can use to
reach fetch.ai
and last but not least about us we are
always looking out for speakers
if you have an idea for a talk that you
want to share with us and that you want
to develop in the talk we'd love to hear
about it
do reach out even if you're not certain
whether the topic is appropriate or not
we're always happy to
give it advice and guidance we're also
looking
for sponsors if you're um from a
corporate entity
and you want to send some goodwill away
as i mentioned before the sponsorship
fee helps us with the
upkeep of the meetup um the
the fees are going to zoom and and other
um online
activities um so do reach out for that
we are recording the meetup and we will
make the recording available
shortly after today's meetup is
finished it will be made available
through the pi data
youtube channel and you can find a link
to that
on the page as well and then last but
not least
if you want to give us a shout out
because you enjoyed the meetup
you can tweet at us at bydatacambridge
or send us an email
at pydatacambridge gmail.com
so then just before i hand it over to
our first speaker of the evening
i want to
emphasize something that ola posted in
the chat if you have any questions
during the uh either of the talks
feel free to post things in the chats or
in the qa function
um we we will have some time after each
talk to to address questions
and do feel free to to reach out and
introduce yourself
and we'll get started with that
so i will stop sharing my screen
and then our first speaker for the
evening is
george
okay okay see my screen good yes you
know
um just as a quick introduction so
um george is going to talk to us today
about using perceptual data to move
towards the future of virtual reality
and george has
received his phd m-a-n-b-a from the
computer lab
laboratory here in cambridge and his
research interests include computer
graphics
specifically high frequency displays and
virtual reality
and previously he's worked as a software
engineer at microsoft
as a vp of engineering at meet elise and
as a
research intern and consultant at
facebook reality labs
and he has a growing interest in
educational research and great
predictions
as he has recently started teaching at
the per school
also here in cambridge so we're glad to
have you
with us tonight george um thank you for
coming and
take it away thank you thank you for the
introduction can you hear me yes
all right and i suppose you can see the
presentation as well yep
perfect lovely all right well
due to and after the introduction i
probably have fewer things to say than i
thought but
indeed as as you were saying so the name
is george danish it's a symbol of funky
spelling failure easy pronunciation
and today i'm going to be talking about
various bits and pieces of my phd
specifically i will be discussing the
need and the use of perceptual data
and how it can be applied in computer
graphics i should hopefully
explain how it can help us move forward
towards the future of virtual reality
just kind of inspiring the title if you
haven't come across these topics before
then don't worry i will give a quick and
gentle introduction in a second
now this slide is probably rendered
rather redundant now but
super quickly i'll just go through this
so and yes i did most of my research
here in cambridge the one i
do want to highlight is that many of
this was done in collaboration with
alexa michalik
who kind of gave a presentation on pi
data cambridge in january i believe
so while he was focusing more on the
theoretical framework
i'm going to spare you most of the
details of of the maths here i'm going
to be focusing on motivation challenges
and applications but if you're
interested by perceptual
research then do check out his
presentation as well
for full context yes so i've worked in a
couple of positions this talk is not
endorsed by anyone at the moment
as i am right now just teaching at the
past
but i did have some form working both at
the university and at facebook
and the resentment talk that i'm doing
today is going to be present inspired by
those two
but first of all then let's talk about
in vr let's talk about what exactly
virtual reality is and while the history
of this technology goes back at least as
far as the 1960s or something
if not further to be honest it has only
gained popularity in the recent years
with the release of the consumer
headsets like the oculus rift and the
htc vive
fundamentally if you haven't come across
it you can think of it like a simulated
experience
that you can enter by putting on a
headset then the headset will display
two different frames for your two eyes
and the aim is to make you believe that
when the stimulus or the imaginary
around you is so
realistic it's so high quality that you
sort of believe that it really
is the world around you a few related
technologies that you might have heard
of are ar and xr
now air stands for augmented reality
which is a modern version of the google
glass if you have come across that one
it basically merges real and virtual
objects into the same scene
and then xr is used normally as an
umbrella term for all of these
technologies
i'm not going to be highlighting all of
these later on so when i say vr you can
sort of think about all of those at the
same time
now what you see on the right here is
considered to be
by many at least to be the first hat set
ever invented
it seems a bit clunky probably by modern
standards and
the only thing i do want to highlight on
that is how it has already one key
property
it's probably one of the first devices
in the history that relies on the
perceptual understanding that two
separate displays
can create a sense of depth now it might
seem trivial but in the rest of the talk
you will see how further insights into
perception have shaped the path of
virtual reality
now let's look at what it would take to
make vr indeed fully realistic which is
sort of the holy grail of graphics
nowadays
the question can be rephrased as how
much data would the image
their frames take that perfectly
represent reality
and probably a classical engineering
answer and i will try to not offend any
engineers on the call
is to create a device and increase it
every possible
create a device and then increase every
possible aspect of it hoping that the
user will be satisfied
for a somewhat perhaps better estimate
you'll need to somehow
rely on the knowledge of the human
visual system to understand what exactly
a vr headset needs to be able to do
now of course visual system is quite
complex so this is going to be just a
very rough approximation but first of
all let's just say that obviously
we have a limited field of view so
roughly the human eye can see 150
degrees horizontally and vertically
so it's going to be 150 by 150.
then we need with an e squared degree
the eye has a finite number of
photoreceptors so it can only see
limited detail
in plain english tiny areas are
integrated by our by our eyes
so there's no need to draw more than the
smallest resolvable line
and if you're interested in all of the
dry beard there then wendell's book on
the foundation of vision will be your go
to guide
now we also have a limited ability to
differentiate between colors
and while there's no clear consensus
here normally people say about far but
five four or five bites per pixel
probably provides enough storage
as long as you're using some kind of
reasonable compression there
and you can see on the left if you don't
have enough colors then you basically
see these weird
bending artifacts
now when it comes to moving objects then
an insufficient number of frames can
cause blurry or druthery emotion
and i'm going to be brave enough and
i'll try to do this over zoom which may
or may not work
now what i'm hoping is if you see the
moving eye tracker then it should
hopefully
look fairly jothery or fairly blurry if
you're trying to follow it
now this is actually one of the many
insights that oculus rift and hdc5 made
very good use of
realizing that you need at least 90
frames per second
which is a bare minimum to avoid vr
sickness
and at last well we have two eyes which
if your mental math is keeping up then
you should get somewhere
around 230 gigabytes per second
and of course you want to keep it in a
very slim hardware
now in contrast what is the reality of
virtual reality if you excuse me the fun
well imagine an htc vive pro look rather
pixelated
the only parameter they do hit is
actually the 90 frames per second
and the reason is because fewer than
that could actually cause users to throw
up
and if you run the maths then you get
roughly about
one gigabytes per second now that's in
contrast to the 230 gigabytes per second
so
even if you bet on the incredibly swift
development of gpus
we simply cannot freeze the required
processing power within the next
16 17 years and even then the form
factor remains a huge issue
because let's be honest nobody wants to
walk around with a couple of rtx cards
just glued onto their head
now don't get me wrong vr headsets are
engineering marvels but since human
perception is
it has final limits basically and it
makes sense to guide our research by
perceptual models
we know for example that the actual
perception and bandwidth of the visual
system is much smaller
so then it becomes a matter of figuring
out where we can remove data
without the observer noticing
and what you see on screen is it's
showing is it's not a new idea by any
means
the fact that rgb subpixels can fool
your brain to hallucinate
a continuous range of wavelengths and
this is a phenomenon called metamerism
it's a classical example of perceptual
insights in graphics
and also in display technologies it's so
ubiquitous though that you probably
don't even think about it consciously
being
a perceptual phenomenon
now let's talk about a few more recent
examples there is one
called trm of temporal resolution
multiplexing
or i like to refer to it as the first
half of my phd
here the idea is that the visual system
is fairly oblivious to flickering
as long as it happens in the fine
details of the image so we do our video
objective large flicker but we don't
really care about small things but
moving around or changing very rapidly
so the idea we had to know there was to
do every other frame in a low resolution
and if you flip between those two very
quickly you can probably get a baby down
and with around 40
saving without actually sacrificing
quality that is
the question is though how much do we
reduce the resolution
and also does it even work
it is also known that the eye cannot
follow moving objects perfectly like the
eye tracker i asked you to follow there
this allows for a range of adaptive
algorithms that favor for example
high resolution it's a high spatial
resolution law of pixels when the image
is stationary
but it will reduce the resolution it
will move fast it will have
a lower lag when the object that you're
tracking is moving fast
now the question of course here is what
do we call and what do we do when the
movement is slow
what constitutes as fast move emotion is
there a threshold
and so where is it i'm not going to go
into too much detail here
but if you're interested then please
feel free to check out those two papers
the technique i will talk more about it
is probably the most popular perceptual
rendering topic nowadays
that is called foveated rendering or gas
contingent rendering as some call it
here the idea is that the eye actually
has a non-uniform resolution
whilst you can see very fine detail in
color around your fixation points
wherever you're looking
our periphery is blurry and mostly
monochromatic
a classical demonstration is well
something that everyone can do at home
if you fancy you can give it a go
is if you extend your arm and you look
at your thumbnail
now it turns out the only thing right
now you would see properly
is your thumbnail and the rest of the
world is just blurry and faded around
you
with almost no color the interesting bit
is that your brain will try to fill in
all that information so
you won't be consciously aware of this
a rendering technique that could exploit
that though is
one that wouldn't even bother generating
most of the information in the periphery
question is though what do we mean by
not rendering most of the information
how much data can be saved there what do
we need to keep what is the eye
sensitive to
ten years ago gunterreta suggested
drawing images of multiple resolution
and just blending them
and what you see on the right there
there's an illustration of that
we have a more recent example because
obviously 10 years in computer science
it feels like a lifetime
this technique is called deep fuvia it
uses advances in deep learning to
reconstruct frames
from an irregular sampling grid so you
basically start off with some very
sparse samples
and you try to reconstruct a full bitmap
image from that
with your experience now if you're
interested in topic you can probably
propose newer and better affiliated
rendering methods
there are many of them out there but how
do you tune those magical numbers those
magic parameters how many samples do you
need
and how do you know whether your
technique even works
now ultimately to calibrate these
algorithms and to validate them
we again have to come back to human
perception we basically have two
questions
if the algorithm targets or two options
rather if the algorithm targets a widely
understood region of perception
such as color for instance or static
images that you might be able to use
some
existing models and you might get of the
whole topic fairly quickly
example might be the visual difference
predictor or color spaces that give you
a fairly good abstraction of how to
manipulate
your information now alternatively
and that is the case for fluviated
rendering i'm afraid we have to start
doing our own psychophysical research
because there's just not enough
information and there are not
enough models out there
so the premise of psychophysical
validation
is that the ultimate consumer is going
to be a human
therefore a human or a group of them are
the most competent judges
of subjective quality if you're
interested in how different experimental
protocols
and then we work out and how the math
behind them works out and do take a look
at alexa's presentation from earlier
this year
here i will rely on his ever civilized
conclusion that data collection
is expensive now he also mentions that
mechanical turk might give you a
compromise where you can maybe just
gather a bit more data even if it's a
bit more noisy
but unfortunately it doesn't really work
with vr and we shall see
in a second why that is
but just to give a simpler example first
of a more classical traditional
psychophysical experiment
this is a frame rate experiment
condensed into a single slide
the idea was what you see there is how
we use the side by side pair vice
comparison setup so the observer would
be literally looking at two monitors
stacked on top of each other and this
helped us figure out how the perceived
quality of different refresh rates
changed with the speed of motion that
you see on screen
now fundamentally you can use such data
to guide for some of the adaptive
rendering methods that i mentioned
earlier
or it might just help you figure out
whether that 165hz monitor that you
really want to buy is worth your money
to give you an idea about scale we had
11 participants with 600 comparisons for
each of those participants
and this counts as a huge large-scale
experiment as far as psychophysics is
concerned
we also needed to conduct it in a lab as
obviously most of the amazon talk users
wouldn't necessarily have 265 hertz gc
monitored at home
now vr poses even more experimental
challenges
side-by-side comparisons are not really
possible because it doesn't make sense
to try to do it
on the two eyes separately because human
perception wouldn't allow you to
actually make
good judgments there so you do need to
present the stimuli
or the things you want to compare in
this case one after another
this is also called a two interval
forced choice design
it can take longer and it's less
reliable than the classical side by side
two alternative force choice
out of flabby experiment is also out of
the question as you need a headset
you probably need an eye tracker and you
also have to be careful not to expose
the observers to vr for too long for
health and safety reasons
just to make it more fun the data you
want to measure has a ridiculously high
dimensionality
it doesn't really fit with the
restriction compare restricted
comparison budget
some of the dimensionalities will
include luminance which is a physical
quantity for how brighter images
it will include contrast spatial
frequencies temporal frequencies
colors velocity of the object you're
trying to
for to follow eccentricity which is the
distance from the retina
how far the distance from the fixation
point how far is it in your
very ferry and of course you do have a
lot of rendering algorithms you could
consider
that you might want to compare
which leads us to the problem we wanted
to address with our joint project that
facebook and cambridge
which i'm happy to be happy to say will
be published now at siggraph
2021 this summer
so the aim here was to capture a data
set that is simple enough
to fit within the budget of a
psychophysical experiment with all cell
mutations
but it still represents visual artifacts
that are typical of foveated renderers
in the paper we also present the
perceptual model which predicts this and
other
data sets actually surprisingly well
i'll focus on the experiment today
though we've budgeted this experiment to
contain roughly 8 000 comparisons which
again is pretty large scale for a
psychophysical experiment
it ended up being roughly 35 observers
with approximately 230 comparisons each
and even that had to be collected over
multiple sessions so we had to invite
people to come back on different days
the stimulus design was quite an
exciting challenge and i hope that some
of the
animations at least show through the
zoom call we wanted the
stimulus to be representative of vr
context content
which had to be a bit more complex than
typical perceptual science stimuli which
usually are just gobble wave that's
flickering some somewhere in your
periphery
but we also wanted to avoid using
photographic and video content
as these tend to contain hard to
parameterize
stimuli in them primarily we knew that
velocity
and velocity in this case of the
on-screen motion that we might want to
follow
is actually quite important and
especially that is so in the periphery
but several other experiments that would
be using 360 videos which is quite an
easy choice in that case they don't
contain sufficient
or representative motion so it might be
for example a fully stationary frame
with maybe some movement in a tree
somewhere nearby but it's hard to
capture it's hard to understand it's
hard
harder than build a model on this is how
we ended up with the
weird floating points that you see on
the right and the different clips there
are just different
contents with different parameters
now the fun bit a bit about this i
suppose if there is a actual
classical vision scientist in the call
they will be freaked out by how complex
it is
and the graphics community will be
talking about how this is not
representative so
we're hoping we hit the sweet spot
somewhere there
if you're interested in vr it looks more
like this so we are filling the whole
field of view
and all the dots will be moving around
right so we also wanted to make sure
that we capture the absence of fluvated
rendering
artifacts and we wanted to do it without
committing to a specific implementation
of affirmative renderer because
we might just capture and overfit the
single artifact there then
so we parameterize soviet rendering
using the sampling rate
which is basically the number of pixels
you actually have those would be the
gray pixels versus the entire image in
this case
and the other parameter we found was the
spatial temporal trade-off which
basically says
whether your final content is going to
be blurry like tunnel vision
like on the top row or is it going to be
flickery like you see on the bottom row
now in the animations you see actually
how fewer samples
will result in lower quality higher
number of samples is going to result in
higher quality
but the interesting thing here already
is that if you look at it carefully it
turns out that
sometimes if you have moving dots around
it
does mask in some of the flicker
this is a similar animation you just
highlight this trade-off
how different velocities will help you
maybe
hide certain artifacts or highlight them
if the image is stationary
now testing all combinations of pairs in
five dimensions
with a result in a in a prohibitively
large number of comparisons
so we instead decided to use a block
design where basically luminance
contrast and velocity which are all the
content parameters
we kept them constant and within each
block
only the sampling rate or the temporal
tradeoff was changed
again we are still in two dimensions so
we further reduce the number of
comparisons by
presenting on the neighboring conditions
as shown on the figure
so basically only the red areas would
have been measured in this case but the
top one is the reference image
at this point we could have explored
some active sampling approach which is a
cool alternative
but after some initial pilots and then
we figured that actually comparisons are
quite meaningful
and a good comparison will be a tricky
one so if you find a comparison too easy
then it's not yielding you too much
information
all right i'll just have a quick teaser
of the results that you can get when
scaling all these pairwise comparisons
on the singular quality scale to get the
scales in this case you would have to
add up all the different comparison
results create your ranking matrices
and they use some models like thurston's
505 model
to actually assume some distribution of
the qualities
what you see there is though that your
vertical axis are going to be your
qualities which will correspond to
roughly linear units velocity being the
three columns
the left column being when the stimulus
is stationary right column when the
stimulus is moving around quite quickly
and this beta parameter is when it's low
that means that we have
very high tunnel vision feelings versus
very flickery images and cool bit is you
can actually see
how this already is highlighting the
difference between different velocities
so it was a
nice reinforcement of our initial
suspicion that velocity matters
one of the things i want to highlight at
this stage though is that we only have
very limited data
so modeling these curves using complex
machine learning methods is not really
feasible there's a very high chance of
overfitting to the specific artifacts of
this mod of this
stimulus instead usual practice is to
use some state-of-the-art method
with free parameters so statistical or
white box
perceptual model that uses some of the
insights that we know
how the visual system works
all right and just a very quick summary
so it turns out perceptual
research helps us guide computer science
graphics research
it gives us some of the very cool
insights that we have it gives you ideas
and a couple of models already if you're
trying to tap into areas that are
already known
plus it gives you a framework for
validation
but data expensive data collection is
quite expensive
so you need to quite often make
compromises and that usually ends up
just meaning that you have to have fewer
comparisons it would be ideal
plus the unfortunate bit is we don't
quite have enough data to make use of mr
models or at least not at this stage
i believe that is the end of the
presentation so if you have any
questions then
i'm more than happy to answer
thank you very much george that was a
wonderful talk
so we have a bit of time for questions
if you have a question for george feel
free to post it in the question and
answer box
and we'll get to it as soon as we can
yeah i might just stop the screen share
so i can see the q a box as well
so while we give it a few minutes i
maybe have a
question that that's maybe um informed
by my
lack of inexperience with the fields but
can you say a little bit about
um when you do the experiments how you
present the the materials to
the the test subjects like what kind of
deployment do you have to uh present the
different
um designs to to your users
yeah quite often there's the computer
science bit so in this case for example
since we are talking about
vr which is bleeding edge technology you
end up writing
quite often almost like a small game
engine or using a game engine to present
your stimuli so
that's quite usually the fun bit there
you tend to think about your stimuli
very carefully
so sometimes if you want to get
photographic content that you would
spend quite a lot of time thinking about
what are the existing 3d photographs 360
photographs
how do you get hold of those so that's
quite an experimental design a dead bit
is also quite
taxing unless more of the technological
challenges
then the actual presentation and at that
time since it's all real-time rendering
in this case
it would need to happen on a fairly
powerful computer who adopted a vr
headset
which we did in the computer lab or
facebook had a dedicated setup for that
in redmond
nice fun experiments because usually it
involves you sitting in the dark as well
because you want to control for
background lighting so you would invite
people to sit in a dark room for about
an hour
and we would try to compensate them with
some amazon bachelors or something to
keep them happy
that was a good strategy
thank you in the meantime we have a
question that came in from alex
i'll read it out loud you can also
follow along
one are these simple scenes a good proxy
for real world scenes
and two is color an important dimension
for vr
right well i think the first one is a
very interesting question where
as i was saying we ended up somewhere in
the middle because
uh perceptual scientists they usually
prefer very very simple stuff like
gabor wavelet sinusoids which are then
very hard to interpret
and to make them meaningful in graphics
and on the other hand
and the graphics community is usually
complaining about anything that doesn't
contain
colorful pictures that wouldn't be an
actual vr content as in it wouldn't be
for example a 3d video
or it wouldn't use one of the highest
end techniques for rendering
i don't know shiny bits of gold or
whatever you want to think about
so that's actually probably one of the
main criticisms that we have received
about this experiment
and the reason is because we are
somewhere in between two communities
there
now our our argument is that the
artifacts are representative hence the
content itself doesn't need to be
representative
so we believe it actually is a fairly
good proxy but it's very hard to make
both communities happy at the same time
and as for the second question color is
a very exciting little one because
usually in these sorts of experiments
color is always comes up because color
is an exciting topic
having said that it turns out color
perception is not as important as
luminance perception so most artifacts
you see are related to
the brightness of an object rather than
the colour of an object
and for that reason if you start
designing experiments and you find
yourself with a limited budget
or if you start designing a model and
you find yourself with a limited
computational budget there the solution
usually is to first remove color
so we've taken taken the liberty of
doing that which is a fairly common
approach
but obviously it does have some impact
so we should
incorporate it sometime in the future
there's no question from the audience i
i'd like to ask a question
um hey um george thanks a lot for the
talk it was really
very interesting um my question is going
to be slightly different from the other
ones i'm
i'm asking this because um you know we
have
often people here in the audience that
are thinking about careers in data
and uh or careers in research i i
noticed you
you you sort of like had this
very research and technology focused
career
and then you decided to go into into
teaching do you want to
say a little bit about the motivation
your motivation to do that and what
excited you about that that's an
interesting one um
i think the main excitement was that i
had the an opportunity to
try and have some teaching before so i
had an opportunity to volunteer before
in schools
i was supervising quite a lot during my
university years
and i figured this is something i really
enjoy doing i'm fairly passionate about
but it is as you say a bit tangential to
to all the technological challenges uh
obviously there are two aspects there
i'm teaching computer science so i still
get to do all the technology except in
this case i get to
try at least to pass down some of that
knowledge and second of all it turns out
the field of academic research on
education is equally interesting
so i'm doing a project now for example
that's related to the of course great
predictions
and it turns out many of the things are
actually using the same psychophysical
measures
for scaling student performance because
it turns out it's just human observer
data
so it does kind of map quite nicely to
other fields as well
very interesting thank you
thank you with that i think we've gone
over the open
questions um i think george said that
he may stick around for a bit if there's
any questions
um if not you can um reach him at
the contact details share during the
talk
and with that then we can move on to
our speakers second speaker for the
evening
while he's getting set up i will
briefly introduce him so mamadou diallo
has
more than 15 years of experience in
survey sampling
and small area estimation and other
topics in statistics
and he currently works for unicef as the
immunization data team lead at the
global level
he holds a phd in statistics from
carleton university in ottawa canada
where he conducted research in small
area estimation
and he has undergrad degrees from laval
university in canada
and university include bernard
and we're happy to have him talk today
about samplix a python package that he
designed for analyzing complex survey
data
thank you very much for having me can
you see
and hear me yes i hear you loud and
clear
thank you good evening everyone thank
you for attending the presentation
so today i'm going to walk you through
how you can analyze complex survey data
using python
so this is mainly an introduction to the
package i have been developing
um so i think
they already introduced my background
but my hand down is here at the
bottom if you want to connect
with me please uh feel free to
send me a message so the plan of the
presentation today so we are going to
discuss
uh an introduction so just we just have
the basics but uh we are mainly going to
focus on a tour
of samplex so we're going to discuss how
you can do
a sample size calculation how you can do
a sample selection uh how you weight
your
sample population how you can use the
package to estimate population
parameters
like mean totals etc and then we will
show
a small example of t-test
so why simplex so when i
started learning python a couple years
ago
there were no comprehensive package to
do survey to analyze survey data
and in the other hand python has a lot
of
rich ecosystem for statistician
to do machine learning data science and
so on
so uh statisticians who work in a space
of official statistics
and our python users they need to have
another
software like r or stata
spss sas etc to do survey
to analyze survey data so the idea of
this package is to bridge that gap
so that if you're a python user you can
remain in the python ecosystem and
analyze
survey data a disclaimer here
the package is in a better version at
this point so the api is still breaking
the apis so if you want to use this for
our production you will have to be
following the
the development or uh maybe
you can wait a little bit uh hopefully
it's gonna be a
stable uh soon at the bottom here i put
a link
where you can find
the documentation in the documentation
we have a tutorial
where you can get yourself familiar with
samplex
so what is survey data so i'm not going
to go into the detail because it's a
vast complex topics
uh but i think we are all familiar with
selecting a
sample from a final finite population
using known probability of selections
often in complex and large surveys
additional futures
are added for to reduce costs for
example
or for operational reasons or for
statistical efficiency to make the
estimated estimate
make the estimates more precise so here
i list a couple of examples for
for example you have stratification
which consists of
grouping your unit yeah putting the unit
that are similar in
in the same groups and then selecting
independently from each group
you have clustering which uh we
we group unit sampling unit
by small clusters and then
you select clusters and within each
cluster you
either select all
the sampling unit in a given cluster or
you can do further uh
selection in those clusters you have
phase sampling calibration etc so there
are
many features that you can uh enhance
your
your sampling strategy with and the idea
is
now you when you do your estimation you
need to take into account
those features so that your estimation
are representative of the population you
wanna
uh you wanna
discuss so here i show um
two questions that we're gonna use to
illustrate
uh the samplex package so the first
question is
what is the household poverty rate in
the u.s
and the second is uh is there a
difference
between a household headed by a woman
versus household headed by one in men in
terms of
poverty rate so to answer this question
i use the acs 2019
so this is the american community survey
uh that i obtained from ipams so
here i i'm just using a subset of the
sam
uh the sample uh the idea is not to do a
rigorous analysis of the
the sample so the numbers i'm going to
show here are not representative of this
of the survey i just wanted some real
life
data to illustrate uh the sampling
apis so here to give you a visual
uh understanding of the data
so i put here the the data frame
selected 15 random households
so each line here is a household you can
see the household id
here you have the region
i have four regions here midwest south
north east
uh uh and the west you have the psu
again a psu is a cluster of households
so put
we i put households randomly together
and from clusters
you have three variables here that are
related to the head of the household
sex race and education you have the
income of the family
and poverty poverty is the derived
variable from
income which depends on the income and
the number of people in the
in the household so if you pull
below a certain threshold your
the flag is one and then the zero
are from the household that are above
the the
poverty uh or the income threshold
so here i show the first example of how
you can use templates to calculate
sample size so you can see from the
module
sampling you i import the class sample
size
and here to calculate sample size you
need the perfect rate
i have it by vision because i want a
stratified design
so in the class here you need to
provide the the parameter the type of
parameters so
here if you want to do a proportion so
you want the proportion of households
that are below
the poverty line
uh the method and then the
stratification is true because you are
doing again a stratified design
and the main method to calculate the
sample size from the class
is calculate which gonna give you a
sample size
uh based on the target that we expect
and the precision that we want and the
precision here is given in terms of a
half
uh confidence interval here is just a
number
but if you want a different number by
a strata stratum then you just provide a
dictionary with the
right specification here you the result
is a dictionary where you see the sample
size by a region
if you want to get a data frame then on
the right here you can
call the method to data frame and then
it's going to give you a
standard data frame here what we
calculated is the number of households
if you
want to get the number of psus then what
i did here is just
a simple uh arithmetic but uh
i'm gonna select 15 household by
psus so i divided the sample size by 15
and rounded up which give me the number
of psus by
region that i'm going to be selecting
from my frame
so now that i calculated the sample size
the next step
is to do this sample selection so here i
give the methodology that i provided by
samplex for doing sample selection you
have simple random selection
and systematic selection these two
provide equal
probability selection the last one
provide an equal probability of
selection and this is the probability
proportion
to size so here the selection is
is done based on some module of size
and these five methodologies here are
what are
what is currently implemented so
as we said earlier we have two stage
design at the first we select psus and
at the second
we have the household so the selection
gonna do
gonna go the same way and in the middle
often
between stage one and stage two we need
to do
some data collection to create a frame
for
the selection at the second stage it's
not always
required if you have the frame you can
do it but often in reality
you don't have the frame and then you go
to the field you do a listing in the
issue that you have selected and then
you use that as your frame
so for selection here uh what you need
to do to use the
samplex you uh download from the module
sampling you download sample selection
and then here the method we're going to
use is ppi systematic
we have a design that is stratified and
we don't
we want to do without replacement so
replacement equal force
means that we don't want to put back the
unit selected
in the bucket before doing the next
selection so every unit can be selected
at most one time
the class the main method for
uh selection is called select and then
you have to provide the sample units
here the
the it's the psu the sizes that we want
to select that we shown
in the previous slide um the
stratification here is by
region and because it's pps proportional
to size we need a size measure
here is the number of household within
uh psu and then if you
obtain the frame so the output of this
is a tuple of three arrays
and i store them directly in the psu
frame
so here i have these last at the right
the last three columns that are the
outcome of these
methods so the first one is a flag to
indicate which
line was selected so which household was
selected
so the last line was selected the
the psu hit indicates how many times it
was
uh selected and because we are doing
without replacement the most
is one and then you have the probability
of selection associated
to this
so now that we have selected the psus we
want to go to the second stage select
the
household and to do that we we have a
listing
also in the 32 selected psus we have a
total of 19 000
plus households so on average if you
look at the distribution here you can
see on average
about five to six hundred household by
psu each of the three thirty two pieces
have on average
together on average uh five to six
hundred household
and from each we're gonna select 15
households using some
sample random selection so to run that
we use the sample selection
class but this time the method is simple
random selection
and when we call the method select we
give it the household
id here the sample size is just 15 is
not a dictionary like
uh previously because we are selecting
15 in all
this uh the strata so we just
can just give 15 and that will work
the stratification here follow the psu
because you want to
for hps you select 15
households the flag to data frame equal
true
provide you with a data frame and then
sample
uh only equal true uh subset
the data to only uh retain the
the sample the the selected units so the
non-selected are excluded
from the output
so now that we have our sample selected
we need to calculate
the weights and to calculate the weights
we're gonna the design weight or the
base weight which are the initial weight
they're going to be just the inverse of
the probability of inclusion or the
inverse of the probability of selection
and to get the probability of selection
is just the product
of the probabilities of selection for
the different stages
we have two so we do the product here to
get
the property and we inverse it to to get
the
design so this is sampling theory it's
not necessarily
anything to do with this samplex just
calculation but what simplex is going to
bring to you
is all the adjustments you need to do to
the weights
so that at the end your final way to
represent still represent
the uh targeted population so
here i list couple of the i list the
adjustment method methods that are
implemented
so you can do non-response adjustment
meaning
moving some of the the weight from the
non-respondent to the respondents
uh calibration when you have auxiliary
variable
with known uh portals or aggregated
value
uh you can use them to to adjust your
weight
normalization is just a technique to
scale your weight
to add up to some uh known uh
some known value replicate weights there
are three methods that are implemented
via
bootstrap and jackknife this will allow
you to
calculate more complex uh statistics
so to do non-response weighting you need
to know the response status of your
variables
and samplex has a standard way
of knowing the status so you have the
any
ineligible r i n
r r for respondent and non-respondent
and so on
so this is the nomenclature understood
by
samplix so if your data
follow a different nomenclature you need
to give the samplex a mapping
dictionary so that you can map and
understand
your classification
so here you can see the variable here
the response status
it's a spelled out respondent
non-respondent and so
on so i provide here the mapping
so that uh samplex understand what is
non-respondent and so on
to to adjust the weight for non-response
i import
the sample weights class
and then i use the method adjust which
is the main one for
doing non-response adjustment so you
provide
the original weight you provide the
classes where you want to do the
adjustment
so it's going to adjust the weight
within vision and race
and then the house the the response
status
so respond and non-responder etc and
then the mapping if it's different from
the standard one that
uh some some places understand so you
can see the result here
so design weight is the original weight
and this was
adjusted to get the non-response weight
and you can see a non-respondent now
have a weight of zero
and this weight was redistributed to the
other unit and that was done by the
class which is based on
uh region and race
oops
so this example here is an example of
calibration
so you can calibrate your weight to to
uh to sum or to to some known totals
or rate or some aggregates so here the
example i
show is by uh region
we know the number of households below
the poverty
rate of the poverty uh line and we know
the number of children
so we're gonna use use the calibrate
method from
the class to calibrate the non-response
weights
using the auxiliary information that we
have above and using the known
uh statistics or controls at the
population level
and we want to do this by uh bioregion
so just to show you here a test
to for you to better understand what
it's doing
after the calibration the weights
gonna provide the same control totals
uh than the one that we knew prior to
our adjustments so the weights have been
adjusted so that poverty
give the same numbers are before and
number of children the same
so that can help in certain cases in
some estimation
methods so for the estimation we have
mainly two broad classes we have the
uh tiler-based estimates and the
replicate based estimates
so for the title-based estimate you can
do proportion mean total ratios
uh and quantiles are not yet implemented
but
are under development so to do an
estimate here what we need what we want
to estimate is the poverty rate which is
a proportion
so i i bring the the appropriate class
here for the tile estimate
and then i call the method estimates
from the class so that's going to
require me to provide
the output variable that i'm interested
in
the weight so we're going to use the
final calibrated weights
and the
the stratification and the psus so
running that i get this output here
where you can see that
the proportions of households
under the poverty line is about
12 and then you have the associated
statistics like the standard error the
confidence interval
etc so the point of providing the design
information is to get these statistics
correct
otherwise the information you will get
will not take into account the
complexity of the design
and will not be uh correct
uh statistics for the
um at the beginning i said one of the
questions is to know whether the
household headed by women's are
similar or the same to the household
headed by
men in with regard to the poverty rate
so to do that i import here from the
categorical model
uh t-test class
and here i say that my sample type is
one sample
because what i want to do here is i have
one sample but i want to compare two
group
from the sample and the compare methods
uh can allow me to specify the variable
of interest
which is the poverty status and then the
groups i want to compare which is sex
male versus female household and then
the design features sample weights
stratification and so on so it's
calculate that
information give me confidence and
shovel and then here the null hypothesis
test is to compare uh the mean or
proportion which is the same in this
case because
zero one variable uh between female and
male
and it can calculate two main class of
statistics the
equal variable the equal
variance assumption and the one that
assume that
an equal variance so you will know your
data to know which one is more
appropriate for you
but here the statistics are provided for
the three alternate
uh alternative hypothesis whether it is
below
or above or a two-sided
test so you can see here the tests are
not
significant
so this will conclude the presentation
so
at this point um i'm working on example
on training
and training material as i mentioned
earlier in the documentation you have
tutorial that will help you follow the
api
and also i'm working on some of these
features
um to to complete the package
so i stopped there for today thank you
very much for
your attention
thank you very much that was a wonderful
talk
so we have a again a couple of minutes
for
questions um if anybody has a question
feel free to post it in the question and
answer box
and maybe while we wait i have a
question of my own
so you showed some of the methodologies
that the package
already provides out of the box um
i don't know a lot about statistics but
i know it's a huge field
and i'm wondering a bit if you have
users that have
methodologies that are not comprised in
your package
how do you recommend or is there a way
for them to
extend your package with for instance
let's say new sampling method or
different estimators
yeah that's a good point yeah absolutely
there are many methods that currently
are not in the package and i i'm trying
to use and will
add and i will be very happy to to get
help to to add them faster
so for example one big idea that i
haven't
touched yet is the area of regression
so we you can use a
stat mode sub models and scikit learn
and etc to do
regression and then you can add weights
but there are many things in the
in the sampling futures that are not
in those ones so stratification
clustering and a lot of things so
that's a huge uh module that's gonna be
adding so if people are interesting
interested that one things that can uh
gonna be very useful cool
thank you um and then maybe just one
quick question
question because you you hinted at it um
so you showed the
statistical tests at the end do you use
stats models
for that under the hood or do you have a
different package for the
statistical calculations
yeah so so what i do is i implement the
algorithm mostly the same
mostly uh by hand but they are
when it's required to do um
to fit a model i use such as uh
stats models because it's probably it
can
in using weight and uh
and the basic
the basic design sampling design you can
get
initial estimate that then you can
further uh
tweak the algorithm to get to get it
more
to what you want but yeah basically i
try to implement
algorithm as as much as possible from
scratch
using mainly numpy um
but then when i get to the sophisticated
modeling then i use some of these
existing packages
oh cool
so in the meantime i'll have a look
don't see any further questions
um hi i can go with one if you
if you don't have any others so yeah
thanks for the presentation
i noticed you got some graphics on your
slides so how do you uh
is simplex integrated with any of the
kind of
famous graphic drawing libraries
yeah yeah so graphics is one of those uh
those package
that uh i was mentioning earlier that i
plan to add but i have not had it yet so
and this report will be nice so the
graphics i showed i use uh
seaborn but i use it after the fact
using the result of the the package
but i plan to add some status some
graphics uh graphic modules to kinda
help visualize some of the results and
how the weights are influencing
the estimates and so on so yeah that's
that's in my
in the roadmap but not implemented yet
cool thanks
okay if there are no further questions
then i think we can
call it today so thank you again to
both of our speakers for presenting
and thank you for um everybody else for
attending um we'll see each other again
hopefully in one month from now for the
31st
installment of the meetup and until then
thank you again for attending and have a
good rest of your day
bye thank you thank you for having me
you